[Musique]
mais bon la gravité la famille john rech
annoncé le roi des fromages
parce que vraiment ça vient de la région
dans le nord de l'italie la région de
parme une petite section de bologne
l'émilie romagne
toute cette section lot de l'italie est
une zone qui est dédiée à la production
du parmigiano reggiano le parmigiano
reggiano est une appellation contrôlée
avec un cahier de charges extrêmement
précis comme nous le souligne patrice
yao kyoto qui importent directement
d'italie le précieux fromage c'est
réglementé par le consortium le
parmigiano reggiano qui fait en sorte
que la production est uniforme à travers
tous les producteurs
[Musique]
je trouve ça important au québec de
parler de cette grande appellation là
parce que à travers la diversité
fromagère à laquelle on a accès c'est
important de comprendre l'origine de
certains produits
yannick achat est un spécialiste des
fromages il donne ici une formation sur
le parmigiano reggiano à l'institut de
tourisme et d'hôtellerie du québec au
canada certaines fromagerie produisent
maintenant des parmesans
comment ces fromages se compare-t-il au
parmigiano reggiano aujourd'hui le
parmesan canadiens vont être assez
différent du parmigiano reggiano je
crois qualitativement c'est un produit
qui est tout aussi intéressant qui peut
côtoyer le parmigiano reggiano dans son
frigo dépendamment des textures qu'on
cherche
l'intensité aromatique peut-être que le
parmigiano reggiano on va en faire un
produit peut être un petit peu plus
gastronomique on peut consommer comme ça
même en morceaux est ce qu'on connaît
mal les parmesans ici où j'ai envie dit
oui parce que je pense que longtemps au
québec on a eu le parmigiano reggiano et
on a eu le fromage près rapper en pot
pour mieux flatter les palets parsemé
salades et légumes du fromage parmesan
râpé traque les choses ont bien évolué
depuis l'arrivée en 1945 de la fameuse
boîte verte de quartier nous aussi avec
taille
nicolas david directeur recherche et
développement de la maison et vieira
nous explique les principales
différences entre le parmigiano reggiano
et le parmesan canadien une des plus
grosse différence c'est que notre lait
est un lait pasteurisé et on est sur un
possédé nous dit industriel avec des
qu'ailleurs en inox en baisse alors que
en italie on est sur des cuves en cuivre
au niveau du
du salage lyon sera salée dans la masse
le fromage alors qu'en italie
le tournage va passer 30 jours en
saumure
parce qu'on salle directement le cahier
le parmesan canadien contient beaucoup
plus de sodium que l'italien la plupart
se situant pour une portion de 30
grammes
entre 300 et 400 mg de sodium alors que
les parmigiano reggiano en contiennent
autour de 200 mg pour la même quantité
une autre différence de vieillissement
dernière étape la finale ici au canada
où parle d'un affinage environs de dix
mois le parmesan canadien et vieilli
dans un emballage plastique alors que le
parmigiano reggiano est affiné à l'air
libre pour une période beaucoup plus
longue en attaque mais john les châles
aux étages et d'un minimum de 12 mois
nous quand on est potes et le parmigiano
reggiano il varie entre 18 24 36 40 mois
+ parmigiano reggiano est âgé plus on
voit une cristallisation à l'intérieur
du fromage le goût est plus prononcée il
ya plus un goût un goût comme de noix et
de plus un goût plus grand plus complexe
on va parler de fruité intense amandes
caramélisées qui vont se retrouver au
niveau à romain c'est parmigiano
reggiano de qualité va ne sera pas trop
c'est trop friable non plus sur le
marché on trouve certains parmesan
canadien en bloc mais on les offre
surtout frappé dans des sacs ou des
contenants rigides
le parmesan canadien par un affinage
plus court nous permet d'avoir si vous
voulez des des filaments ou des copeaux
qui sont assez différent du parmigiano
reggiano nous avons demandé à yann et de
commenter à l'aveuglé un échantillonnage
de produits canadiens râpées ou en
copeaux parmi les plus vendus une pointe
de sel qui était assez marqué c'est un
produit qu'on voit surtout utilisé pour
j'ai envie de dire assaisonner un plat
[Musique]
des gens ni si on a quelque chose de
plus plus subtil puis sensible on est
vraiment sur des notes lactique ça sent
les frais ça ça j'ai même envie de dire
un fromage frais tout simplement on a un
bel équilibre s'effriter ces lactique
on sent le bar le côté bas fonds du même
les ja pointe de sel
on reste sur des arômes lactique
recruter on a un petit côté russe les
fois qu'on peut retrouver dans des chais
d'or dans des parmigiano reggiano à un
tout petit peu mais sans excès
des notes lactique beurre crème beurre
fondu
des qualités aromatiques sont fort
intéressantes puis fort appréciée dans
les plats dans la cuisine
la plupart des fromages canadiens vent
du rap et contiennent de la cellulose
naturellement présente dans les végétaux
et les sans danger pour l'être humain
dont la cellule c'est un anti
agglomérant qu'on utilise dans le cas du
fromage râpé pour éviter que les grains
que les filaments de rap est ce que
l'ensemble c'est certain que le
parmigiano reggiano on n'aurait pas
tendance à retrouver la cellulose parce
que le produit temps plus sec
il ne colle pas ensemble maintenant
qu'en est il du prix pour un par média
noorigian ou de 24 mois on paiera entre
30 et 40 dollars le kilo dans les
épiceries italienne 45 $ aux fromageries
spécialisés et jusqu'à 55 dollars le
kilo un supermarché
dépendamment du nombre d'intermédiaires
qui intervient dans le processus
on a des écarts de prix importants pour
les parmesans canadien la fourchette de
prix se situe entre 22 et 48 dollars de
kiel certains sont fait principalement
de substances laitières ou substances
laitières modifier des sous produits bon
marché de la production laitière
il est donc important de vérifier la
liste d'ingrédients pour voir si on est
en présence de parmesan ou d'un produit
de fromage avec parmesan les parmesans
canadien par par la diversité le style
de production différents d'une maison à
locaux au canada ça nous permet d'avoir
plus de possibilités au niveau de
l'utilisation
c'est un aux produits sans l'autre a dû
coûter c'est un ce produit qui a
définitivement des des bons côtés
le parmesan canadien et un bon fromage
avec ce qu'on a ici tandis que le
parmigiano reggiano vraiment le roi des
fromages avec ce qu'ils ont un taillis